public Senna en partenariat avec
l'équipe vous présente sport etc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous je suis ravie de vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de
sport etc à moins de 500 jours de la
cérémonie d'ouverture de Paris 2024 la
magie des jeux ne perd pas encore nous
en parlerons largement dans leur que
nous allons passer ensemble nous
reviendrons également sur la situation
du foot féminin et sur la liberté
d'expression qui est un peu malmenée
dans le sport tout de suite le sommaire
billet jugé trop cher transport
incertain le vent de critiques qui
souffle sur les jeux est-il justifié
pourquoi la flamme olympique ne
brille-t-elle pas encore dans les yeux
des Français la Fédération
Internationale de l'Automobile veut
museler ses pilotes la BBC suspend Gary
Léna cœur ancienne gloire du ballon rond
est présentateur vedette pour un tweet
critique peut-on encore s'exprimer comme
on veut dans le sport la sélectionneuse
des Bleus Corinne diacre a été démise de
ses fonctions suite à la fronde d'une
partie des joueuses de l'équipe de
France comment en est-on arrivé là la
gouvernance dans le sport est à revoir
quelle piste pour réformer
[Musique]
pour m'accompagner aujourd'hui j'ai le
plaisir d'accueillir Laurent Lafont
sénateur centriste du Val-de-Marne et
président de la commission des affaires
culturelles en charge également des
questions de sport guide rue membres du
Comité international olympique et ancien
ministre des Sports Rachel pretty grand
reporter au journal L'Équipe notre
partenaire dans cette émission et Vikash
doraso ancien international de football
consultant pour l'Équipe TV et Canal+
Afrique bonjour à tous les quatre nous
sommes à 496 jours de la cérémonie
d'ouverture des Jeux Olympiques oui j'ai
compté en même temps c'est facile mardi
dernier c'était moins 500 pour l'instant
on entend parler que de motifs
d'inquiétude sécurité transport question
géopolitique coût de l'organisation prix
des places on est loin de la magie des
jeux et c'est l'affiche de sport etc
[Musique]
s'il est loin ce 13 septembre 2017 quand
tout le monde se réjouissait que Paris
est décroché les jeux aujourd'hui un peu
plus d'un an un peu plus d'un an et demi
des premiers tours de piste les
polémiques s'enchaînent vous êtes tous
au courant de elles sont nombreuses
c'est polémiques monsieur le sénateur
est-ce que vous êtes inquiet quand vous
entendez toutes ces polémiques inquiets
quant à l'organisation de ces Jeux
Olympiques non d'abord je pense que la
période est plutôt de manière générale à
avoir un esprit critique rien n'avoir un
esprit positif il y a pas de raison que
les Jeux Olympiques
un état d'esprit un peu général moi je
crois pas qu'il y a des inquiétudes à
avoir on sait que maintenant on rentre
dans un compte à rebours vous l'avez
vous-même fait il y a quelques instants
l'échéance s'approche de jour en jour et
on mesure peut-être mieux aujourd'hui la
complexité d'organiser que représente
l'organisation des des JO du point de
vue d'insécurité du point de vue des
transports du point de vue aussi
financier on est sur un événement
puissant et quand on aborde un sujet on
voit bien que c'est pas des un état de
la puissance de ces de cet événement est
incommensurable par rapport à tout ce
qu'on connaît jusqu'à présent donc
forcément il faut s'y préparer il y a
aujourd'hui des questions c'est pas
parce qu'on a des questions aujourd'hui
que demain on ne trouvera pas les
réponses
vous parliez justement du du fait qu'on
réalise l'ampleur de de la tâche face à
des jeux olympiques guidrude est-ce
qu'il y a des choses qui vous inquiètent
dans l'organisation je sais pas je pense
à la sécurité non
il faut je crois qu'il faut faire la
distinction entre les critiques et les
questions
et dans les critiques il y a aussi des
critiques positives de temps en temps
moi personnellement je suis pas du tout
inquiet parce que les mêmes questions se
sont posées j'ai vécu mon avec mon grand
âge j'ai vécu tous les jeux olympiques
pratiquement depuis 1972 les questions
que les Français se posent aujourd'hui
sont celles qui étaient posées à Rio à
Londres à Barcelone à Sydney etc et
qu'ils l'ont été aussi à Montréal à
Munich et Munich on en reparlera
j'espère parce que c'était il y avait le
terrorisme là qui a été actif donc pour
ma part
on aura l'occasion d'y revenir
certainement en parlant par exemple de
la CMU l'ouverture mais je suis pour ma
part tout à fait confiant les choses
olympiques seront une fête populaire il
faut simplement attendre qu'il soit là
et je sais que à chaque président de CIO
à l'issue des différentes sessions des
jeux ont toujours dit c'était des bons
jeux etc etc parce que tout le monde
était satisfait donc voilà mais qui est
des questions qui se posent avant c'est
normal et comme disait monsieur le
silencier on est en France
positives je suis désolé de trouver des
critiques positives en ce moment les
jeux j'ai beaucoup de mal
alors je dirais que il y a eu beaucoup
de critiques sur la billetterie puisque
c'est la clé mais il y a eu des
critiques positifs si il y a plein de
gens je me fais pas l'avocat du Kojo
mais il y a plein de gens qui ont dit
bah j'ai réussi à avoir des billets sauf
qu'ils étaient moins nombreux que ceux
qui malheureusement n'ont pas trouvé les
des billets accessibles et notamment les
fameux billets à 24 euros il y a un
million de billets à 24 euros donc 700
000 pour le grand public 400 000 ont été
vendus mais résultat sur les 3 millions
de ce 250 000 qui ont pu acheter des
billets il y en a très peu qui ont pu
avoir ces fameux sésame à 24 euros on
reviendra sur la sur le prix des billets
que certains jugent trop cher mais je le
disais mardi dernier c'était la
célébration des du j-500 Emmanuel Macron
le président de la République a sonné la
mobilisation générale tout en rappelant
les enjeux des Jeux Olympiques pour
Paris et pour la France
500 jours avant le début donc d'une
compétition exceptionnelle pour le monde
entier durant laquelle on va essayer
d'abord de recevoir la planète dans les
meilleures conditions possibles de
sécurité d'organisation de
responsabilité sociale et écologique et
évidemment durant laquelle nous
organiserons mais on essaiera aussi
d'avoir le maximum de médailles 500
jours pour réussir 500 jours pour que
ces Jeux olympiques et paralympiques en
France sont un formidable succès sportif
mais aussi national c'était la
mobilisation générale là c'est l'appel à
toutes les forces de la Nation pour pour
que ces jeux soient réussis
oui je crois que de toute façon le
président de la République a raison de
dire que c'est pas les JO ça sera pas le
succès que d'une équipe que du Kojo ce
sera le succès de notre pays dans son
dans son entièreté et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut que on crée un certain
dynamisme et qui pour l'instant n'est
pas vraiment là mais moi je suis pas
tellement préoccupé par ça il y a
d'autres sujets d'actualité qui c'est
encore loin et puis il y a d'autres
sujets d'actualité qui sont un peu
anxiogènes en ce moment donc c'est
normal que les Français soient pris par
des sujets comme les retraites qui sont
plus dans leur préoccupations immédiate
que de se dire dans un an et demi on
aura la chance de de pouvoir vivre ces
jeux est-ce que c'est pas un peu vicash
de raceau du bashing que l'on voit en
France je pense notamment à cette à
cette une de Marianne je vais vous citer
juste une phrase d'un des articles
principaux on a du mal à faire la
différence entre les cinq anneaux
olympiques et les 9 cercles de l'enfer
on y va fort là quand même
moi je me demande est-ce que ça va être
utile c'est Jeux Olympiques et par
exemple on aurait pu demander aux
Parisiens s'ils avaient envie de
recevoir les les JO pourquoi on reçoit
les JO et qu'est-ce qui va se passer
après les JO et ça va être sur
l'héritage il parlait de du nouveau
social et au niveau écologique aussi
évidemment il y a un vrai défi qui les
grandes compétitions avec beaucoup de
monde qui se déplacent beaucoup de monde
qui va être là et après sur la sécurité
récemment on a sur la question
écologique on le sait les les activités
sportives les plus écologiques enfin les
compétitions sportives les plus
écologiques c'est celles qui n'ont pas
lieu parce que c'est celle qui bah ça
pose évidemment la question des grandes
compétitions je veux dire la dernière
Coupe du Monde c'est jouer
en Russie
j’étais joueur de foot et je suis en
tant que joueur content de pouvoir y
participer maintenant je suis dans la
société civile et un autre regard mais
pour au niveau de la sécurité la
dernière fois qu'on a reçu une grande
compétition c'était au Stade de France
ça s'est très mal passé
la question des problèmes la question
des transports est une question majeure
Rachel on parle de 500 000 personnes à
déplacer chaque jour alors je vais juste
citer Laurent pros qui est le directeur
général d'Île-de-France mobilité qui a
dit c'est comme si on devait gérer 50
stades de France par jour alors
l'analogie est peut-être pas évidente
avec ce qui s'est passé lors de la
dernière finale de la Ligue des
Champions mais c'est une vraie question
déplacer autant de monde on conseille
quoi au Parisien de quitter Paris non
pas tout à fait alors leur empreinte
dans sa fait une conférence vendredi
dernier pour présenter le plan le
premier plan mobilité en fait
l'Île-de-France mobilité qui sera qui
sera mis en place et bien sûr
amender modifier en fonction de en
fonction des calendriers mais en fait ça
serait bien un jour de pointe chaque
jour du mois d'août donc en fonction des
sessions ils devront adopter des plans
différents et nous ils nous ont parlé
d'une application qui permettra de
savoir en fonction d'où vous allez quel
chemin emprunter et par exemple pour le
Stade de France faudra pas hésiter à
prendre une autre ligne pour quitte à
marcher le bison Futé des Jeux
Olympiques exactement si ça marche mais
il faudra aller autre part que par où le
chemin par lequel on a l'habitude de
passer quitte à marcher plus d'un
kilomètre pour atteindre le stade de
France
c'est normal qu'on dise aujourd'hui la
flamme olympique ne brille pas encore
dans les yeux des Français c'est normal
elle est pas là encore la flamme mais
elle commence à scintiller quand même
elle arrivera à Marseille
par le Belem etc etc bon et là souvent
sur le papier c'est absolument
magnifique c'est magnifique et ce sera
magnifique écoutez pour prendre nos
voisins sans aller au Brésil ou à Sydney
à Rio à Sydney
Londres a su le faire Barcelone a su le
faire je vois pas pourquoi les Français
n'y arriveraient pas et vous mettez la
pression sinon
[Rires]
propre ça a raison mais en fait c'est
pas tout à fait vrai c'est
45 40 ou 45 championnats du monde dans
la même cazaine mais tout ne se passe
pas en un lieu il y a le stade il y a le
ver-sur-marne il y a Marseille il y a un
gars etc oui ça c'est autre chose bon
donc moi je me fais pas de souci sur les
capacités de la France d'organiser ce
genre de trucs la Coupe du monde de
football en 98 c'est bien passé les
championnats du monde d'athlétisme en
2003 se sont bien passés la Coupe
d'Europe en France c'est bien passé bon
il y a eu le malheureux comment
dirais-je épisode de que signaler vital
sur le la finale de la Ligue des
Champions il faut en tenir les
conséquences justement pour se préparer
et puis n'oublions pas non plus que dans
l'organisation il y a quand même un
partenaire essentiel c'est le
savoir-faire du Comité olympique
international j'en profite pour
juste notre réalisateur peut faire un
gros plan sur le Holi que vous avez sur
la veste alors
ça veut dire olympien et olympien c'est
une grande association mondiale dans le
la présidente française et Valérie
barloie champion olympique discrim et le
président international Joël Bouzou qui
lui est champion du monde de Pat elon et
ça ça regroupe tout ce celles et ceux
qui ont participé aux Jeux olympiques et
donc c'est un honneur une fierté que de
toujours mettre je savais vous y teniez
particulièrement
moi je vais revenir sur les choses qui
fâchent encore dans dans ces jeux et
c'est le sujet qui a occupé à peu près
tous mes confrères c'est dernière
semaine c'est le coût des places pour
beaucoup de gens ce coup est exorbitant
l'un des slogans du kojob que je
rappelle c'est des jeux populaires et
accessibles à tous alors lors de la
première vente de billets il fallait
acheter trois impact de trois épreuves
on a quand même le sentiment que le prix
en a choqué plus d'un alors ma question
est la suivante est-ce que c'est parce
qu'on a pas l'habitude de mettre
beaucoup d'argent pour voir une
compétition de sport en France est-ce
qu'on a pas conscience du côté
exceptionnel ou est-ce que dans la
période dans laquelle on vit avec les
problèmes d'inflation le prix des places
a choqué plus d'un aspirant spectateurs
et donc il y a eu un décalage
d'abord le prix des places il est à
mettre au regard un regard avec le prix
de l'événement
les Jeux Olympiques c'est un coup élevé
et s'il y a une pression comme ça
notamment sur le COJO pour faire en
sorte que il y a un équilibre financier
qui soit trouvé et que on reste dans une
épure qui soit raisonnable je crois que
c'est un des défis principaux de des JO
de Paris forcément ça veut dire qu'il y
aura une participation demandée à ceux
qui auront la chance de venir
assister à différentes manifestations on
peut légitimement s'interroger sur quand
on est dans cette logique là qui est un
peu une logique de sport spectacle
est-ce qu'on est encore dans du sport
populaire je crois que cette question
elle se pose pas que pour les JO
regardez le prix d'une plat d'un place
d'une place de d'un match de Ligue 1
les tarifs sont aussi élevés c'est un
phénomène global du sport évidemment on
le voit et c'est un effet c'est les JO
donc c'est un effet loupe qui
extrêmement fort une prise de conscience
qui vient moi je crois qu'on peut pas
reprocher au Kojo qui a intégré me
semble-t-il cette problématique
financière qui lui a été donnée de
manière très claire et qui du coup bah
dit si vous voulez que je reste dans les
purs c'est une conséquence sur sur les
prix et le fait que les événements
sportifs de cette ampleur aujourd'hui
c'est du spectacle
que le Kojo aurait peut-être dû dire un
peu plus clairement qu'ils avaient
besoin de cet argent puisque c'est un
tiers de leur budget qui est de 4
milliards 380 en disant c'est plus
audible comme ça oui en disant on est
obligé de faire le grand écart alors oui
on veut des jeux populaires avec des
places à 24 euros mais oui on doit
rentabiliser avec des places beaucoup
plus cher pour nous permettre
d'équilibrer le budget et sinon on est
dans le dur donc et c'est ce décalage
parfois de dans leur discours qui a fait
que les gens étaient déçus surtout que
avec le système de Pâques bien sûr 24
euros ça fait 72 si on en prend trois
mais les places ont très vite augmenté
la différence avec le football le Paris
Saint-Germain par exemple le Parc des
Princes et l'entreprise privée c'est
quand même une énorme différence alors
il y a évidemment de l'argent privé dans
l'organisation du des JO mais par
exemple le Stade de France qui a été
installé
en Seine-Saint-Denis parce que c'est un
endroit populaire et pour faire
participer et développer quelque chose à
mon avis c'est pas passé grand chose au
niveau des quartiers populaires au
niveau des au niveau social d'ailleurs
c'est aussi pour ça qu'il y a eu un vrai
problème pendant le dernier match parce
qu'en fait c'est tous ces gens toute
cette population sont exclus donc c'est
une vraie question qu'est-ce qui va se
passer pour les gens des quartiers
populaires si on dit que c'est populaire
et finalement ils ont pas accès en fait
c'est pas pour eux quoi c'est pour les
gens qui ont les moyens d'aller voir les
JO donc moi ça me pose un vrai problème
et pour l'instant un homme est satisfait
c'est le président du kojob Tony
estanguay il considère que cette
première vente de billets est un succès
alors nous on est effectivement
aujourd'hui confronté à deux enjeux
principaux c'est d'un côté de réussir à
financer les Jeux Olympiques à et
paralympique à 96% par de l'argent privé
la billetterie c'est un tiers de notre
budget donc c'est très important pour
Paris 2024 de maximiser les revenus
générés par la billetterie et on est sur
des tarifs qui sont comparables aux
éditions passées donc on n'est pas sur
des tarifs qui sont plus importants mais
qui permettent quand même dans notre
stratégie tarifaire d'avoir 4 millions
de billets à 50 euros et moins un
million de billets à 24 euros certes il
y a un million de billets à plus de 200
euros au total mais encore une fois la
très grande majorité des billets reste à
des tarifs assez accessibles
des tarifs assez accessibles oui ça
s'est toujours passé comme ça de toute
façon quelque soit les villes où il y a
eu des Jeux Olympiques et puis il y a
l'offre et la demande vous payez pas le
même prix quand vous allez au resto s'il
vous plaît à neuf maillots du foie gras
ou du caviar oui mais là c'est un peu
pareil avec tout le respect que j'ai
pour les athlètes qui vont participer
aux Jeux Olympiques quand vous achetez
des places un petit peu cher pour des
séries donc pour les premières épreuves
je parle pas des finales là vous savez
pas si vous allez manger du caviar ou de
l’œuf Mayo ah bah c'est souvent du
caviar quand vous allez voir ce sont de
grands athlètes
[Rires]
c'est la première fois qu'on présente ce
genre de distribution de billets ou
d'achat de billets il faut quand même
je suis pas toujours d'accord avec Tony
estanguay mais là il faut reconnaître
quelques jours a quand même fait de une
chose très très bien il y a un million
de billets à 24 euros
je sais pas peu importe il y avait 30%
des billets à Londres qui étaient à 23
euros
mais c'est le nombre de billets mais
après bon bah après et quand vous allez
à l'Opéra Garnier ou à l'Opéra Bastille
et vous n'avez pas vous payez pas que 10
euros non plus hein
etc etc non plus changer les prix et
puis il y a des collectivités locales
vitales parler à juste titre de la
Seine-Saint-Denis la 510 le département
achète 40000 € justement pour ces
ressortir ça 40 000 places ils ont
demandé ils ont mis un petit coup de
pression
[Musique]
donc si vous objectivement c'est c'est
un faux problème et il y a aussi comme
le disait le sénateur le problème des
ressources parce que c'est c'est cet
argent ce qui va aussi financer cette
grande fête que qui aura lieu avec les
Jeux Olympiques
voilà on va le dire on va expliquer à
tout le monde Comité international
olympique
en fait ça coûte cher d'organiser des
jeux est-ce que ça va être possible de
continuer dans un seul pays on sait que
les prochains auront lieu à Los Angeles
mais si je prends l'exemple des coupes
du monde les coupes du monde les
prochaines pourraient être organisées
par plusieurs pays je pense notamment à
la annoncé Mohamed 5 le roi du Maroc il
a annoncé une candidature commune entre
le Maroc l'Espagne et le Portugal est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui un pays une ville encore
les moyens d'organiser des Jeux
Olympiques oui dans la Charte olympique
c'est sûrement un pays mais une ville
qui organise des jeux
ça reste à on n'est pas on n'est pas
fermé non plus le CIO s'est évolué ça
dépendra du président mais il peut aussi
mettre sur le sur le tapis de la session
sur le dans un déroulé de session la
possibilité d'avoir plusieurs villes qui
s'associent par exemple ça pourrait être
une proximité pareil Bruxelles par
exemple ou Paris Berlin ou d'autres dans
d'autres pays ça c'est tout à fait
possible mais il faut modifier la char
te olympique à ce moment-là on a une
prochaine vente de billets qui aura lieu
ça risque de changer un petit peu cette
appréciation du public puisque ce seront
des billets individuels et là il y aura
encore des billets à 24 euros donc
peut-être qu'à ce moment-là on va
commencer à faire briller les yeux des
Français je rappelle que la prochaine
vague commence à partir du 11 mai là je
me suis inscrit il faut s'inscrire
il n'y aura que 150000 billets à 24
euros donc premier arrivé premier servi
alors ça c'est ma vie je peux me
permettre ce serait intéressant de voir
combien de Français
souscriront à la deuxième candidature
parce que la première était quand même
un succès
ce qui n'était pas une évidence il y a
quelques temps on se dit 158 pays qui
ont été intéressés qui ont acheté des
places oui et dans la partie il y a
beaucoup de Français
les les JO après moi je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ce que vous dites c'est de
ratio sur le fait qu'il faut qu'il y ait
un accès de tous là en l'occurrence
l'accès de tous il est assuré par les
collectivités un peu l'état parce que
l'État aussi acheté des de l'État et
100000 billets
du Secours populaire oui
je crois après qu'il faut permettre un
autre accès il y a des populations à
proximité si on voit les événements à
côté de chez eux et qu'il n'y accède pas
c'est un souci il y a des populations
qui sont éloignées des Jeux Olympiques
je pense notamment aux populations qui
sont en province enfin aux gens qui sont
en province ou qui sont les zones
rurales il faut aussi créer un moyen de
faire un lien entre les Jeux Olympiques
il faut pas que les Jeux Olympiques
soient uniquement un événement Paris et
que d'une partie de la population
française qui était ce qui était un
point essentiel dans le souci et la
volonté de Gérard Larcher parce que j'ai
assisté en sa présence à des discussions
dans la période de candidature et il
insistait beaucoup sur le fait que ce
soit les Jeux olympiques de la France
qui ont lieu à Paris mais les Olympiques
de la France alors ce sera les Jeux
olympiques de la France les Jeux
olympiques de Paris mais une question
reste posée et elle va rester posée
encore un bon petit moment il y
aura-t-il des athlètes russes et
biélorusses à Paris en 2024 monsieur le
sénateur
écoutez ce que la question pour
l'instant elle n'est pas tranchée et de
toute façon c'est le CIO qui est le
dernier elle est pas tranchée mais elle
est bien avancée si j'ai bien compris
parce que les les athlètes qui vont
concourir aux Jeux Olympiques 2024 ils
sont pas sélectionnés en juillet 2024
ils vont faire l'objet d'un procession
de sélection sur les épreuves sportives
bien entendu par chacune des fédérations
et pour certaines fédérations ça a déjà
commencé tout à fait et donc certaines
fédérations déjà répondu à la question
notamment les scribes je crois qu'il y
en a trois qui ont accepté jusqu'à
présent que les athlètes russes
concourent après ce sera aussi Yéo
d'arbitrer de trancher d'autoriser tout
à fait les athlètes à concourir aux JO
de concourir sous les couleurs russes ou
éventuellement
neutre mais pour l'instant j'ai
l'impression
me corrigera que les fédérations sont
plutôt en train de dire on n'accepte pas
les Russes dans dans pas tout si j'ai
bien compris
et il doit y en avoir alors l'escrime a
accepté les athlètes russes et biélorus
acceptée mais celle qui qui sont pour le
moment sur le fait de refuser elle c'est
la moyenne les moins nombreuses mais on
va écouter on va écouter les certains
athlètes Ukrainiens qui ont déjà
entendre leur voix ça doit être pour eux
non pas une punition mais ça doit les
mettre dans une position inconfortable
qui les oblige à expliquer pourquoi ils
ne prennent pas la parole ils doivent
agir ils doivent changer le système dans
leur pays parce que le silence c'est en
fait donner son aval à tout ça
ils ont détruit notre pays et tuer
beaucoup de gens des enfants des
sportifs sont morts aussi et c'est
vraiment déchirant ils ne peuvent plus
concourir avec personne
c'est une question qui se serait qui
s'est posée dans le football la Russie
ne participe plus aux compétitions
internationales de football
l'UEFA la FIFA pour la première fois
alors qu'elle refuse de faire de la
politique elle impose aux joueurs de
foot aux sportif notamment de faire de
la politique elle a pris des positions
politiques donc c'est un peu maintenant
ils sont piégés et voilà il va falloir
le faire tout le temps et il y a des
conflits partout dans le monde et ils
ont décidé là évidemment voilà il y a un
pays qui agresse un autre pays c'est
proche de chez nous on est tous très
touchés ils ont essayé de prendre
position très vite voilà donc évidemment
moi un sportif j'ai envie de lui
permettre de alors sans quelle ligne
national sans qu'ils puissent porter un
drapeau etc c'est tellement violent
voilà mais voilà il y a c'est compliqué
à prendre une vraie décision si le SIO
qui va trancher j'ai entendu la ministre
aussi l'autre fois à la radio parler
tout ça c'est difficile de savoir ce
qu'il faut faire et c'est difficile
d'imaginer de priver d'un athlète d'un
moment extraordinaire quoi le plus beau
moment de sa carrière c'est compliqué
voilà après il y a le risque de boycott
aussi des Ukrainiens et d'autres et
d'autres fédérations par an de
solidarité je pense qu'il faut se dire
que les JO sont dans 500 jours on n'est
pas obligé
personnellement si vous me posez la
question je je dirais que si les JO
avaient lieu dans 3 mois il faudrait
refuser les les athlètes russes on ne
sait pas quel sera l'état du conflit en
Ukraine dans dans un an donc on n'est
pas obligé de donner une réponse
aujourd'hui pour un événement qui a lieu
dans dans un an et demi il y a une
question qui se pose c'est évident et il
faudra y répondre mais
n'y répondons pas trop tôt je moi je
serai extrêmement vigilant
personnellement sur cette question je ça
me gênerait profondément que nous
accueillons en France des athlètes
russes si le conflit est dans l'état de
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui mais
les jeux c'est dans 500 jours il peut se
passer des choses d'ici là n'anticipons
pas forcément des réponses exactement
juste la première question sur ce
que je suis vraiment au cœur du sujet là
avec le CIO
récemment Thomas bar a fait le président
du CIO a fait une vision conférence avec
tous les membres du CIO avec tous les
présidents de fédération internationales
avec les athlètes faut savoir quand même
que ce conflit et surtout occidental
vous les africains se sont prononcés
lundi dernier à Angers à Angers Alger
pour justement ils sont tous que ce soit
les athlètes ou les pays les comités
nationaux olympiques africains pour la
participation des athlètes russes et
biélorusses comme les asiatiques comme
les Sud-Américains qui se posent des
questions une partie de l'Europe et les
États-Unis bon ça c'est la première
chose moi je suis pour ma part et je
l'ai toujours dit et c'est l'honneur de
la France de ne jamais avoir boycoté
quel que soit quelques manifestations
que ce soit olympiques les jeux je suis
pour la participation des athlètes
russes et Bill russes parce que comme le
disait vite
[Musique]
etc au début du mois lors d'un match de
championnats de France entre le Portel
et Roanne trois supporters sont apparus
grimés de noir ce qu'on appelle le
Blackface le club du Portel a indiqué
que c'était un clin d'oeil à l'ancien
coach qui était parti en Martinique la
Ligue Nationale de Basket par la voie de
son président Alain Bérard à la condamné
ce geste qualifiant cet acte comme
considéré comme profondément raciste
depuis le 19e siècle elle a saisi la
commission de discipline de la ligne
alors c'est un carton rouge il ne s'agit
pas de savoir si c'est trois supporters
sont racistes ou non d'ailleurs quel que
soit la réponse ce genre d'attitude
tient historiquement à des origines
racistes et coloniales la couleur de
peau n'est pas un déguisement je tiens à
préciser que
cette attitude se Blackface déguisement
appelé le comme vous voulez c'est pas
encore quelque chose qui est puni dans
les textes en tout cas la situation de
la Ligue Nationale de Basket est
compliquée ils ont évidemment fait appel
à la discipline est-ce qu'il faut être
plus précis dans les textes je pense que
le sport il est le reflet de notre
société
les questions qui se posent dans notre
société elles se posent dans le sport et
de ce point de vue là le sport est une
est un reflet d'un certain nombre de
tensions que nous connaissons dans notre
société c'est aussi une vitrine et parce
que c'est une vitrine il faut qu'il ait
des réponses claires et net et qu'elles
ne repose pas uniquement sur les
responsables fédéraux même si les
responsables fédéraux ont comme leur nom
l'indique une responsabilité qu'ils
doivent exercer mais je pense que du
côté de des pouvoirs publics et
peut-être de la loi s'il y a des
insuffisances dans la loi il faut les
renforcer en tout cas il faut être clair
sur le fait que certains propos
certaines attitudes ne sont pas
acceptables dans les stades dans les
différents équipements sportifs que ce
soit lors de manifestations profites
enfin de sport professionnel ou que ce
soit aussi dans du sport amateur
on l'entend très souvent d'ailleurs sur
les sur les terrains de football les
terrains de football sont pas exemples
de ce genre d'attitude raciste et elles
ont tendance alors je ne sais pas si
elles ont tendance à se multiplier ou on
a tendance à en parler un peu plus oui
oui ça arrive assez souvent trop souvent
et les joueurs aussi réagissent
maintenant on entend il y a des micros
un peu partout donc on peut repérer ce
qui se passe et je pense que ça
progresse pas je pense pas que ça
intéresse beaucoup les les dirigeants de
de la Fédée on l'a vu avec Noël le grec
tu es quand même président de la
Fédération Française de foot qui disait
qu'il y avait voilà on pourra en parler
mais voilà qui qui disait qu'il y avait
aucun problème de racisme d'homophobie
et de sexisme dans le football donc
voilà alors que le premier statut le
premier point des statuts de la FFF
c'est quand même de lutter contre toutes
les discriminations et les inégalités
dans le sport le sport amateur le sport
professionnel donc voilà le Blackface
les Noirs disent ils veulent pas de
Backface donc on fait pas de Backface et
le président du club de basket a dit que
c'était super marrant mais c'était un
hommage etc c'est super rigolo c'est
pour ça que c'est important
de rappeler
moi je pense qu'il y a d'autres
problèmes que soulève la représentation
dans les dans les sphères de de pouvoir
et on va en parler dans quelques
instants justement de la réforme des
instances avant cela on va parler de
l'autorisation ou non de pouvoir
s'exprimer pour les sportifs donc on
voit bien que certains supporters
mériteraient d'être un petit peu plus
cadré les sportifs eux aimeraient qu'on
cadre un tout petit peu moins leurs
paroles par le de sport ou tais-toi
c'est le hors-piste de sport etc
[Musique]
alors on se débute saison de Formule 1
la FIA Fédération Internationale de
l'Automobile a décidé d'interdire au
pilote tout commentaire politique
religieux ou personnel sans accord
préalable préalable alors évidemment
c'était sans compter sur la personnalité
de Lewis Hamilton qui est sans doute
l'un des sportifs les plus engagés de sa
génération notamment pour la défense des
droits LGBT il a immédiatement déclaré
que personne ne l'empêcherait de parler
on le connaît suffisamment pour savoir
que c'est vrai et il explique pourquoi
je ne suis pas simplement un pilote de
Formule 1 qui peut profiter de son
succès et continuer de vivre sa vie
l'air de rien Twitter est une plateforme
qui peut vraiment déclencher des
changements susciter des conversations
et c'est un début il faut provoquer ces
discussions gênantes et tenir pour
responsables ceux qui ont jusqu'à l'or
été à l'aise avec le statu quo en
maintenant l'oppression de certaines
personnes et on ne les incluant pas ça
me frustre on peut provoquer du
changement et je veux faire partie de
ceux qui aident ce changement et faire
en sorte que les gens se sentent inclus
pendant les jeux les sportifs ont le
droit de dire ce qu'ils veulent comme
ils veulent ou ils veulent en dehors du
stade en dehors du stade ou de la
piscine ou j'aurais simplement revenir
sur la question du racisme si je suis
pas intervenu parce que les propos du
sénateur la France sont plein de bon
sens et ça vient d'un ancien
parlementaire donc
et aussi le visage c'est inacceptable
c'est inaccessoire et il faut prendre
toutes les mesures pour pour lutter tout
ça et ça n'existe pas d'hier c'est ça
fait un moment que ça dure bon ça c'est
la première chose pour ce qui est de
l'expression des athlètes
c'est leur liberté au jeu on n'a pas le
droit de le faire
sur le podium par exemple souvenez-vous
de des
fermer il y a quand même deux ou trois
épisodes dans l'histoire des jeux là ils
sont fractionnés
il faut garder un petit peu le côté un
peu sacré du podium et du Stade
olympique et de l'enceinte olympique ou
de l'enceinte sportive mais on peut le
faire à l'extérieur il y a évidemment de
moments il y a
une belle exposition olympique
ça sert pas à ça c'est pour faire autre
chose les Jeux Olympiques ça sert
justement à aller dans le sens que nous
disions tout à l'heure c'est-à-dire le
rapprochement des peuples le fait que
vous avez des gens des jeunes des moins
jeunes de toutes catégories de toutes
origines de toute sensibilité de toutes
les couleurs qui sont heureux de se
retrouver ensemble et c'est ça et
Jean-Claude Killy disait on dit toujours
que le monde le le village
le monde est un village et le village
olympique lui c'est le monde et pendant
15 jours vous avez 10 ou 12000 personnes
qui sont contents d'être ensemble et qui
et qui se comprennent pour que quand il
parle pas toujours la même langue mais
il y a là c'est pas l'espéranto c'est
l'olympio et il se comprenne c'est pour
ça qu'il faut lutter c'est pour ça que
la magie des jeux c'est ça aussi je
pense que Lewis Hamilton serait presque
d'accord avec vous sauf sur la
possibilité de s'exprimer lui il
s'exprime quand il est sur le fond
de m'exprimer
d'ailleurs on a demandé à un homme de
plus s'exprimer en tout cas la BBC
suspendu et Gary Lina car Gary car c'est
une grande gloire du football anglais
c'est aussi le présentateur de la plus
vieille émission de football au
Royaume-Uni match of the day il s'était
mis sur Twitter de la politique
migratoire du gouvernement britannique
résultat il a été suspendu ça fait
intolé extraordinaire en Angleterre et
ce week-end là il y avait personne à la
présentation de match of the day puisque
personne n'a accepté de le remplacer et
surtout aucun joueur n'a accepté de
s'exprimer au micro de la BBC vicash
est-ce qu'une solidarité comme ça ça
existerait en France oui je suis
persuadé que les footballeurs sont très
solidaires les uns des autres ils
auraient pu faire la même chose c'est
beaucoup de footballeurs qu'on se qu'on
soutenu
je trouve ça formidable moi je suis pour
qu'on désobéisse moi le monde change les
jeunes générations arrivent elles sont
plus d'accord n'accepte plus à Milton
c'est incroyable ce qu'il fait il est
avec Mercedes qui font pour l'inclusion
pour lutter contre les discriminations
c'est formidable ou qui continue parce
qu'en fait il faut que si alors le CIO
mais les fédérations changent elles
aussi dans l'organisation dans la
gouvernance dans la représentation et
qu'elle voit aussi qui se passe des
choses un peu partout et qu'il faut
entendre tous ces jeunes qui qui veulent
du changement voilà et Hamilton il veut
du changement Marcus reichford ils ont
les joueurs anglais ont posé un genou à
terre pour Black climater c'était
interdit au début et après la Ligue a
accepté il y a des choses qui sont on
peut pas
laisser enfin faire comme si ça
n'existait pas et donc évidemment le
soutien-gare est formidable mais lui il
est formidable aussi oui parce que il a
critiqué la politique migratoire du
gouvernement britannique il accueille
lui-même des des réfugiés chez lui mais
ce qui est intéressant c'était de voir
l'unité du du monde du foot et du monde
du sport
tout à fait même en France on a vu bien
au-delà des spécialistes de foot et des
joueurs une solidarité pour dire il peut
dire ce qu'il veut et voilà et il a une
liberté de parole qui doit qui doit être
respecté oui
mais non tout le monde arrête
le meilleur cash le plus prendre c'est
mon cas personnel régulièrement je vois
je peux entendre ou lire que je suis
aigri je suis pas aigri je suis pas gris
du tout au contraire euphorique mais je
suis enthousiaste pour les Jeux
Olympiques parce que je sais que ça va
bien se passer et je crois qu'il faut
faire la différence en poser des
questions entre les voix discordantes et
les voix différentes je peux avoir de
temps en temps exprimer des souhaits ou
poser des questions sur une voix
différente que la voix officielle c'est
la Digital c'est ce qui a dit Monsieur
de sénateur c'est ce qu'a dit Rachel
et bon c'est le dialogue ça c'est ça
fait progresser le monde et je crois
qu'il faut l'accepter et sinon il
d'abord moi je connais pas dans une
démocratie une règle qui interdit à qui
que ce soit qu'on soit sportif artiste
artisans etc journaliste de s'exprimer
on est dans un monde de liberté il faut
bien sûr respecter cela après la
question se pose dans le cas des
événements sportifs compte tenu de les
faire amplificateur que à ces cons ces
événements et en particulier les Jeux
Olympiques on le voit bien avec la loi
Jo où on est en train de effectivement
alors pour des pas pour les sportifs
mais pour des gens qui rentreraient dans
le stade et qui effectivement
utiliseraient l'événement sportif pour
pour dans un acte plus militant et de
perturber l'événement sportif ça
concernerait pas en l'occurrence ce
dispositif les les sportifs je pense que
il y a un esprit de responsabilité qui
doit se mettre en
œuvre là-dessus interdire tout
expression
provisoire mais
fragiliser les événements en les
utilisant de manière un peu systématique
pour des revendications certes légitimes
mais qui détournent un peu l'événement
parce que c'est difficile parce que si
on laisse la parole complètement ouverte
alors tout le monde doit accepter le
soutien comme on l'a vu d'une joueuse de
tennis russe qui est arrivée sur le
terrain avec un maillot du Spartac on
accepte sans commentaire Neymar qui
soutient bolsonaro l'ancien président
d'extrême droite du Brésil si on libère
la parole elle est libérée pour tous
privés
mais quand la FIFA décide de d'exclure
la
Russie des compétitions il fait de la
politique bien sûr clairement donc après
elle interdit aux sportifs de façon
individuelle alors évidemment il y a des
causes qui moi quand Neymar soutien
bolsonaro je suis pas content j'ai plus
envie de l'aimer alors que c'est un
émergeur du monde donc vraiment il y a
voilà faut mais oui si on profite pas de
ces grands moments parce que évidemment
pendant la compétition on est tous
réunis mais il y a plein de gens qui
souffrent d'homophobie de racisme et
c'est ces gens-là qui ont envie
d'entendre la méthode les soutenir ils
ont besoin de des grandes voix et même
aussi des gens qui font leur communale
par exemple ils ont besoin d'entendre
tout ça donc c'est important et moi
c'est important aussi que les joueurs de
foot se fassent entendre reprennent un
peu de pouvoir parce que quand Hamilton
il se fait matraquer maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'il a comme choix est-ce
qu'il peut être exclu est-ce qu'il peut
continuer à prendre position ou pas un
jour de foot qui prend position il peut
être exclu il peut prendre une amende il
peut être suspendu regardez l'exemple
aux États-Unis quand il a mis le genou à
terre il a été première
le puits retravailler maintenant on va
enchaîner sur du football féminin
justement on va garder cette idée que
les joueurs les joueuses peuvent prendre
la parole
on va parler football féminin et
instance sportive c'est la prolongation
de sport etc
[Musique]
Noël le Great n'est plus le président de
la Fédération Française de Football
Corinne diacre n'est plus la
sélectionneuse de l'équipe de France de
football féminin l'un a remis sa
démission l'autre a été remercié c'est
la mise en retrait des joueuses cadres
de l'équipe de France Wendy renard
Marie-Antoinette Catteau cadidjatou
Diani qui sont à l'origine du
licenciement de Corinne diacre comment
est-ce qu'on en est arrivé la vie cash
alors il y a le il y a le Greg déjà
c'est lui qui dit beaucoup de choses
on l'a vu il a il avait décidé un peu
seul et puis après c'est un peu c'est un
peu dérapé il y a un vrai après dans le
système pyramidal voilà donc moi je
pense qu'il faudrait changer tout ça
pour que des nouvelles personnes
puissent émerger voilà que tout le monde
puisse voter avoir sa voix qu'elle soit
vraiment représentée qu'on change aussi
le visage de la jeunesse des sportifs
des joueurs de foot par exemple dans le
football après Corinne diacre moi je
suis embêté parce que des joueuses de
foot des femmes se rebellent mais elles
exclut donc de nouveau une femme en plus
je sais pas trop pourquoi c'est parce
qu'elle fait pas les bons choix parce
qu'elle choisit des joueuses qui sont
pas j'ai pas vu de trucs de harcèlement
par exemple je sais pas je sais pas quoi
penser de de cette histoire en tout cas
c'est maintenant c'est étrange parce
qu'elles ont elles ont viré leur
entraîneuse donc maintenant c'est une
autre personne qui va arriver en sachant
peu maintenant se faire virer par les
nouvelles enfin c'est alors c'est super
étrange qui s'est passé Rachel pretty
est-ce qu'on est pas arrivé à ce genre
de situation parce que depuis trois ans
les joueuses de l'équipe de France
tiraient la sonnette d'alarme comme
l'expliquait efficace de rassaut il y
avait que Noël le grec qui décidait et
donc personne écoutait ces femmes là oui
ça fait longtemps je pense que il y a un
malaise dans l'équipe de France féminine
et puis là le fait que Wendy renard qui
est quand même la joueuse cadre
emblématique et dit je me mets en
retrait quitte à louper la compétition
de cet été je pense que voilà suivi par
les deux les deux joueuses du PSG ça a
fait bouger un peu les lignes alors moi
non plus parler de crêpage de chignon
oui c'est vrai merci de le rappeler
je pense l'une des choses les pires
qu'on oui je pense que ça allait au-delà
du crépage de chignon puisque je suis
pas dans l'équipe foot mais mais les
filles parlaient de monarchie du fait de
ne pas pouvoir s'exprimer voilà est-ce
qu'il y avait des questions aussi un peu
plus techniques sur des entraînements
qui n'étaient pas bon elle est adaptée
je ne sais pas vraiment mais pour
qu'elle tire vraiment comme vous dites
la sonnette d'alarme et disent on arrête
au point de se mettre en danger
elle-même sportivement je pense que
surtout qu'un groupe de travail a été
mis en place en urgence par les
fédérations françaises de football et a
fait le constat d'une fracture très
importante avec des joueuses cadres ça
on l'a vu mais aussi un décalage avec
les exigences du très haut niveau donc
il y avait des problèmes d'entraînement
enfin il y avait plein de plein de
problèmes qui ont cristallisé cette
colère mais Laurent Lafont il a fallu un
coup de force en fait des joueuses de
l'équipe de France pour qui est du
changement est-ce que c'est pas lié
comme le disait vicash dhdoraso a un
problème de gouvernance
d'organisation de de la gouvernance dans
la Fédération française de football
de l'équipe de France de football parce
que j'estime que c'est pas mon rôle moi
d'élude de sur une décision interne à la
fédération en revanche il y a une
réflexion plus globale et la question de
l'équipe de France de football est un
des aspects des questions mais vous avez
raison il y a il y a la fédération
française de rugby à la question la
porte il y a eu la question à la porte
il y a eu la question le grec elle est à
la Fédération française de football on
voit bien que les grandes fédérations et
notamment celle qui
gère des des gros budgets qui sont sous
des pressions importantes il y a une
question à la fois sur le statut
associatif le statutistif est-il
toujours apté compte tenu des enjeux
financiers qui sont derrière et une
question de gouvernance c'est à dire du
fait que comme dans toute grande
structures il doit y avoir un pouvoir et
un contre-pouvoir et le contre-pouvoir
doit avoir des moyens de contrôle de
vérification qui doit y avoir une
transparence dans les décisions qui sont
prises il y a certainement matière à
réflexion et à décision concernant les
grandes fédérations françaises de sport
mais justement
ayant ce qui était porté par Roxana
maracinin nous l'ancienne ministre des
Sports et vous avez d'ailleurs beaucoup
participé à la à la construction de
cette loi elle a été votée il y a un peu
plus d'un an est-ce que elle était
censée justement démocratisée le sport
en France elle était censée travailler
sur la façon dont sont
gérées ou diriger les fédérations
sportives est-ce que en un an on n'a pas
eu le temps de tout mettre en place
est-ce qu'il est un petit peu trop tôt
pour juger est-ce qu'il y a des choses à
changer déjà
en fait il est un peu trop tôt pour
juger la loi marais signée à nous mais
on peut d'ores et déjà dire que la loi
maracinée à nous ne répondra pas à ces
questions c'était pas ça qui était visé
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être le regret à
avoir c'est de se dire on savait quand
même qu'il y avait quelques questions
qui se posaient dans les fédérations
qu'on a cité et la loi n'a pas répondu à
ces questions là mais ce qui était visé
c'était plus des sujets de société il y
avait notamment la question de la parité
dans les institutions le renouvellement
des instances où on limite le nombre de
oui mais à trois mandats mais de toute
façon comme si il était entamé on avait
droit à quatre Noël le Great c'est 12
ans à la tête de la Fédération Française
de
trois mandat donc ça ne répond pas à la
question je pense vraiment que c'est une
question de de représentation au sein de
ces grandes fédérations de des
oppositions des différentes sensibilités
qui est un vrai contrôle qui soit fait
en externe ça c'est le rôle du ministère
mais aussi en interne par un système
démocratique et il faut arriver à le
mettre en place c'est pas si simple que
ça bien sûr c'est pas si simple que ça
on n'est pas comme dans un système
institutionnel dans l'Assemblée
nationale ou ou au Sénat on est dans un
système associatif avec des gens il y a
des diversités de profils entre les
grands responsables ça serait quoi un
contre-pouvoir vous parlez le
contre-pouvoir
j'ai pas la réponse très honnêtement
j'ai pas la réponse à ce jour si on
regarde les deux fédérations rugby est
foot on voit
le rôle et l'autonomie des comités
d'éthique les comités d'éthique sont des
structures intéressantes mais
manifestement elles ont pas assez
d'autonomie par rapport à aux directions
de de des fédérations mais ce sont des
rôles
enfin c'est des structures intéressantes
il faut voir si on peut les les
renforcer après il faut que dans les
modes de scrutin dans les différentes
élections on assure une représentation
de l'ensemble des des courants et que
les différentes parties prenantes aux
élections et accès aux instances
dirigeantes certes il faut qu'il y ait
une majorité pour que les décisions se
prennent mais il faut aussi qu'il y ait
une minorité qui puisse effectuer un
rôle de contrôle c'est le principe d'une
démocratie en fait
le sénateur a tout à fait raison je
crois qu'il faut arriver à une c'est ce
que souhaite justement ce qu'a proposé
Jean-François Villotte qui a été pendant
cinq ans qui est avocat qui a été
directeur de cabinet Jean-François
Lamour et le premier président de la
Commission de régulation des jeux en
ligne et qui fait des propositions que
je prends pour ma part tout à fait saine
et je crois que nous pouvons par exemple
en initiative le sénateur et moi de
souhaiter que la ministre réunisse
quelques personnes de de
totalement Inde mais qui connaissent le
sport y compris surtout des fédérations
et les collations qui a mis en place un
milieu d'air castéral c'est des gens qui
connaissent le sport quand même quoi les
j'ai pas compris
Marie-Georges Buffet qui est l'ancienne
ministre des Sports Stéphane Diagana
champion du monde 400 mètres
sont exaucés
moi je suis là depuis longtemps et donc
j'ai l'intention d'y rester encore un
moment parce que ça c'est quand même
quelque chose de très important cette
nouvelle gouvernance parce que les
problèmes se posent dans les fédérales
se sont posés au football
au rugby un peu handball pour des
raisons différentes mais dans les sports
de glace moi quand j'étais ministre il a
fallu que je fasse règle des problèmes
aussi la Fédération française
d'équitation et j'ai mis Nelson Paillou
comme un petit peu pas comme curateur
mais comme arbitre général
et les problèmes se posent également au
Comité olympique français donc ce qu'on
demande ce qu'on souhaite c'est que
d'avoir pouvoir avoir référence à une
autorité indépendante pour le Comité
olympique ça peut être ça peut être le
CIO bien sûr ça peut être l'inspection
générale ça peut être la Cour des
comptes
il faut pas aller jusqu'à la justice
mais pourquoi pas simplement parce que
on veut on a besoin d'un peu de
transparence et ça c'est je crois que
c'est le souhait de beaucoup les caches
on avait besoin de transparence dans la
Fédération Française de fonds
il aurait pu quand même de partir en
dehors en étant désolé non elle est
partie en disant j'ai rien fait et il a
été replacé à la FIFA pour un poste qui
est super il prend il a été confirmé
donc c'est génial en fait les mecs on
les déplace on le met ailleurs et puis
le comité d'éthique là moi quand je vois
les personnes qui ont été
tout seul candidats
c'est super démocratique et quand je
vois le comité d'éthique qui a été
choisi ce sont des personnes qui sont
déjà dans les instances depuis très
longtemps il va rien se passer ils
veulent moi je sens qu'il va pas y avoir
de changement comme d'habitude oui mais
il y a ce côté national mis en place par
Amélie ou Dr Castéra Rachel pretty on
peut en attendre quoi
présidente avec Stéphane Diagana alors
on en attend peut-être beaucoup pour
l'instant puisque on a vu comme vous le
disiez dans les dans les fédérations en
fait il y a des comités d'éthique mais
ils sont pas saisis il y a plusieurs
présidents quand ils sont venus débattre
chez nous qui nous ont dit mais nous on
a un comité d'éthique on le saisit pas
forcément on s'est dit encore moins
celui du CNOSF puisque certains savaient
même pas qu'il existait donc là le fait
d'avoir des personnalités un peu en
dehors pourra peut-être faire faciliter
le fait de tirer la sonnette et de dire
bah là ça va pas qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire après reste à savoir quels seront
vraiment les pouvoirs de ce comité on
attend des propositions pour l'automne
et la ministre des Sports a annoncé que
de toute façon qu'une décision ne serait
prise avant les Jeux
donc si c'est le temps que ça mûrisse
quand même absolument et si je peux me
permettre il faut savoir aussi que parmi
les dirigeants et c'est pas vital qui va
me dire le contraire parce qu'il a
reconnu comme moi il y en a certains
c'est vrai qu'ils s'accroche comme des
Bernies
peut-être qu'on devrait encourager la
mixité ça a été d'ailleurs une des une
des questions très difficiles de la de
la loi maracinée à nous
oui parce que la personne décompte la
parité évidemment et la mixité la
difficulté c'est d'arriver à faire
fonctionner des associations des
fédérations et donc des associations
dans lequel parfois on se bouscule pas
pour prendre des responsabilités il faut
on a tous à l'esprit
etc
et au niveau au niveau des départements
donc on avait aussi le souci de dire
bien sûr il faut montrer la direction et
la direction c'est celle de la parité il
y a pas d'ambiguïté mais est-ce que
l'ensemble des fédérations sportives
sont prêtes à y aller non pas par
volonté mais faute de combattant
j'allais dire et j'ai une dernière
question est-ce que les télévisions
françaises sont prêtes à se lancer dans
la Coupe du Monde féminine très
sincèrement nous sommes à 4 mois du
début de la Coupe du Monde Féminine
c'est pas une compétition en bas de mon
immeuble c'est la Coupe du Monde
Féminine et il n'y a toujours pas de
diffuseur Rachel pretty vous avez des
informations elle va être diffusée
quelque part cette coupe du monde
j'aimerais bien
alors je sais pas vraiment s'il y a la
place ici nous avons vocation à faire
cela mais c'est quand même un vrai souci
oui vicash
à faire moi je pense c'est de mettre
l'égalité salariale au niveau de la
Fédération au niveau des équipes
nationales c'est-à-dire là c'est pas
l'égalité c'est la première chose à
faire en fait c'est le premier truc les
Américains ont porté plainte contre leur
fédération elles ont gagné on va être le
dernier pays à mettre l'égalité
généralement encore les derniers à ce
niveau là c'est un truc fondamental les
joueurs de foot et les joueuses de foot
doivent avoir le même salaire quand
elles représentent l'équipe nationale
merci beaucoup merci à tous les quatre
merci à vous de nous avoir suivi un
grand merci à toutes les équipes
techniques et éditoriales qui m'aident à
préparer cette émission et nous
retrouvons le mois prochain pour un
nouveau numéro de sport etc sur Public
Sénat à bientôt
[Musique]
Public Sénat en partenariat avec
l'équipe vous a présenté sport etc